hello and welcome to this video playing
my master customer that is a shrewder
right from Chile yeah kiss you people
would probably hate me for it when I
will play my my children again I've done
great positions against him with this
opening so I'm continuing to do that it
didn't do all that well on them you
squat points but the positions i have a
really good it's kind of debatable if i
should take on page six sometimes it's
an idea sometimes not i'm currently
happy with with this if i get the rooks
traded in this position i'm completely
ok so let's see now i have to see that
the Queen has expelled him how to do
that it's not that easy actually
again pick an attack be five here in
this position slightly awkward okay if
it wins be five I'm in bad bad shape
quite clearly but if I don't if I don't
do that my position is completely okay
so he wants to play the night to a
three-year think this is this is a DM
okay I mean I can go before here just
close everything down you can do that
then you might enter with the Queen
again I don't want that so let's take
control over this yeah I've gotten a
good position again against it with this
line at least I'm okay with this oh no
that's not good that's not allow before
should do that that should should
activate my bishop somehow let's see
Bishop over to h6 is an idea but
currently i'm okay with the bishop
covering it hmm 26 Ivan cover the d6
porn I wonder if the e-file is actually
important whether i should do something
like that
try putting a night on g4
here I can just wonder if he has any
idea or if it's just shuffling around
it's often difficult to say because he
shuffled around quite a lot also in the
other games like back and forth and you
oh he's doing something so we had an
idea he had an idea
yeah it was that was a child yet
actually taking was not a great
proposition so I avoided that yeah so
what is the thing is he threatening that
something there let's see
typical or something what and ending is
completely okay and it would be at least
quite surprising if it wasn't we see
some are winning the six and I don't see
arrow I don't know maybe night somewhere
have we had a hello I try to their time
warning so we managed to harass my
bishop down
check that was completely unnecessary to
give him at least this hope that you
would get something on the pawns
especially considering that it was
rather white we had to be careful at one
point in sending still a draw in this
position wise
check check black forfeit Sontag this
guy is just great just a great player he
doesn't want a single game yet on
positioning as we know a single one and
this is the kind of gave me some times
have you any way I managed promise not
to complain too much and yeah so when I
mean I really wanted this kind of
position because I had a couple of games
against him that were like that he never
got anywhere and was rather worse okay
well this is the kind of way to not play
it from white trade everything on the
queenside here nothing much is going on
he actually would this be formed he
tried something which really concern me
but I think the position was still ok at
one point E as usual switch to just hop
doing nothing and try to be on time now
nothing's going on the creature radius
is pretty bad actually I mean just to
make some pressure you should keep the
Queen's on but ok in the ending Black is
slightly better but you probably cannot
win some miss something Bishop g4 yeah
winsa porn or something like that or
what is said yeah okay yeah we are
material him yeah became we both played
quickly I knew that they would have this
kind of
time situation and this waltz away i
took just to make it simpler but my
daddy we have a total draw well i could
have won at one point there should be
five wins hmm i am sucks pond I mean so
2 a.m. okay so I have to do to play it a
bit differently I you have some
practical a kid I can always go here I
shouldn't even have come down anyway I
feel as I'll play this again I mean yes
he doesn't have a single clue how to
play against the setup and the only way
it can happen is with the with the time
and I just needed like one second to win
this game at the end or at least draw
anyway guys thanks for watching